i see stuff like this
and it makes me cringe it actually makes
me cringe because i've been that broke
dude before who had no money and i've
been sleeping on friends couches and
i've been that guy that's made a lot of
money six figures plus plus plus plus
but i've always saved that money so i
can invest so when i see a story like
this i'm thinking what are you doing
people what are you doing so this is the
most common mistake i see in money
management this is going to be a huge
lesson
on living above
your means all right let's get into it
so this is an article from the motley
fool we respect them a lot
we partner up with usa today they've got
a great personal finance section i read
all their stuff i read business insider
i read cnbc i read it all motley fool's
got some good stuff so here's the
article 40
40
of americans making a hundred thousand
dollars a year are living
paycheck to paycheck
did you get me on that one david one
more time yes i'm going to say that one
more time i'm kind of freaking me out
right now i'm not talking about
household i'm talking about individuals
40 of americans making a hundred
thousand dollars
or more
are living paycheck to paycheck so here
we go let's get into this bad boy so you
know everybody's obviously trying to
reach you know that symbolic six figures
i'm making six figures now bro yeah six
figures killing it i'm killing it that's
awesome how many people
best guess what percentage
of americans are making 100 000 or more
today best guess what do you got i got
10
20 percent
let us know in the comments we're we're
watching the comments right now david
you're tracking comments i'm tracking
comments comments track of the 100k
vanessa
what percentage of americans today
are making a hundred thousand dollars or
more what do you guess
oh
six percent six percent yeah not five
plus six all right you want to know the
answer
okay you said how long i uh i said ten
you said ten and you said six it's
almost like you're you're picking my
brain here if you add those up david i
know you're not a math guy ted
and six what does that equal it's a hard
16. that's a hard 16 and that is your
answer ding ding ding ding ding
sixteen percent of americans are making
a hundred thousand dollars or more so
it's not the one percent it's not the
crazy i think the number is you gotta
make about four hundred thousand dollars
or more to be in the quote unquote one
percent let's see what the people are
saying out there unique b said twenty
percent victor said seven we got three
we got seven we got five so people are
some 25
sherry in the house michael coleman 20
the answer is 16. so people aren't far
off you know how much that equates to
that's 28 million americans
making 100 g's oh mo but this and this
is the this is the point of this article
you got sixteen percent of americans
making a hundred thousand dollars or
more
it's 28 million people
but here's the point of the article what
happens when they make that money
what happens so according to this report
yeah right the motley fool 40 of these
people are living paycheck to paycheck
so this is you know there's a song when
i heard this song i was doing a
man on the street episode of rolling
loud the initial rolling line not the
one i did with you first one i did it's
a few years ago we went to rolling loud
that was crazy fun time actually people
were better
financially
than we thought yeah you'd be like
smarter than we thought yeah
but basically this i heard this song and
the song goes like this spend that [ __ ]
spend that [ __ ]
spend a check and get it right back you
ever heard that song it's about a guy
called day day no i'm like don't do it
do it don't spend that [ __ ] you're not
gonna get it right back don't listen to
it it ain't gonna happen don't listen to
day day
anyway day day apparently a lot of
people are listening to that did that
spend that [ __ ] and they're not getting
it right back or maybe they expecting to
get it right back yeah but when [ __ ]
hits the fan they might not get it back
so here's let's get into basically
the spend that [ __ ]
get it right back approach you're making
a hundred thousand dollars or more what
happens to these americans right
let's get into why this is happening
there's gonna be two sections number one
the basics just straight numbers
straight math and then we'll get into
the behavioral side of things so let's
get into why this is happening these are
the basics number one
housing costs are going up we've all
seen this over the last year right
everything that's going on with the
pandemic people can't wait to buy a
house things are getting more expensive
so according to realtor.com legitimate
legitimate website they know their stuff
the median rent for the 50 largest metro
areas
was up to sixteen hundred dollars this
summer that's for a one bedroom that's
how they base it on a one bedroom and
then obviously things go up from there
that's up eight percent from 2020. so
that marks the highest rent ever for 44
out of 50 of the largest metro areas
okay so
rents are going up
things are getting more expensive
obviously a hundred thousand dollars
doesn't go as far in certain cities so
if we're talking the 50 largest metro
areas
largest the most expensive cities in
america clearly new york city
san francisco san jose area la
boston's up there honolulu hawaii
is up there those are obviously the top
most expensive cities but then you also
got cities like
detroit
atlanta
charlotte right where your hundred
thousand dollars might go a little bit
further so let's just factor that in
certain cities you know more bang for
your buck than other cities you make a
hundred thousand dollars in new york
you're you're you're average you make a
hundred thousand dollars in detroit
not too shallow the castle king of the
castle
yeah here we go
so
obviously rents are going up a little
bit things are more expensive we get it
what else is happening right there we're
talking basics right now
before we get into behavioral
we're talking basic so healthcare costs
of god you know how much healthcare's uh
you know out of pocket how much it's
gone up in the last couple decades no
clue six
six six x
six x six fold so oh wow you know you
might have been paying a hundred bucks
for health insurance a couple decades
ago now you may be paying 400
as an example or 600 yeah right things
are going up things are going up things
are going up so healthcare certainly has
you know that's obamacare we won't get
all started that's not a political show
but healthcare's costs have gone up so
that's taken more of a chunk of your
paycheck what else just basic
necessities bro basic necessities what
food
power gas people were freaking out when
gas was going up earlier this summer
inflation inflation inflation those are
some of the basics so costs are
obviously going up but david vanessa my
friends at home valuetainment
there's a sneakier problem
there's a sneakier problem out there
what is it do you want to know what it
is
it's something called
lifestyle creep
oh my god the creeps turn it off the
creeps are out the place is doing out at
night yeah lifestyle creep now you might
be saying
what's this lifestyle creep bro
who's creeping who's creeping on the
comments you see creepy people hear me i
see dead people i see creepy people
what's going on with these creeps let me
tell you about these creeps because the
people out there that are making money
they creeping they creeping
right
so lifestyle creep
is when your standard of living improves
as your discretionary income rises and
former luxuries
now become
the new
necessities let me say that again
lifestyle creep is when your standard of
living improves you're making some more
money you got some more discretionary
income life's good and now the former
things that were luxuries
now they're necessities you know we talk
about having a budget a 50 30 20 rule 50
go to your needs 30 to your wants 20 to
your savings and paying off debt there's
a there's a formula to this it's not
like how do i do this i don't know
there's a formula there's a formula we
talked about that last time other person
who just couldn't save any money yeah i
told them 50 30 20 rule but here's what
happens with this lifestyle creep they
develop what is known as
that deserve mentality
well you know
i'm working hard
i'm making money
i deserve some nice things hell yeah i
deserve something treat yourself treat
yourself it's time to treat yourself i
mean right
i mean she right so now maybe you were
making 50 grand now you're making 100
grand right maybe you're making 60 now
you're making 120. maybe you're making
90 now you're at 150 whatever it is
now you got that deserved mentality it's
time
to treat yourself so maybe
you were driving a
2014 honda
it's time for a new bmw baby right maybe
you got a little casio watch time to get
that rolex
right maybe you were sitting in economy
now fly first class baby on first class
maybe i'll fly private
chat thank you david so maybe you know
maybe you just you know you dress nice
you dress normal now it's time for a
fresh outfit
it's that treat yourself mentality this
is lifestyle creep so listen we're
talking about the creeps i know we're
joking and
people start to spend more of their
discretionary income so look one thing i
will say is you know obviously
as you start to do better and you start
to make more money it's natural
to want to reward yourself
right like of course
you have the key to more things give the
key to more things like what's the last
thing that you bought you're like yeah i
uh
time for me to treat myself believe it
or not it was uh this this year's shirt
yeah
what you got uh chelsea chelsea fc
i know that jack it ain't new you wear
that every day wear this every day
production coordinating vanessa what's
the last thing you said time for me to
treat myself
this watch actually okay how much did
you drop on that
150 okay nothing crazy nothing's crazy
so it's it's fine
to reward yourself there's no problem
with that it was months ago okay bye
okay
um but it's important to define your
splurge let's remember that define your
splurge so what do i mean by that it's
time for me to splurge i want something
what's the one thing one key word one
thing that you really want something
that brings you
joy all right you know what i've been
working hard
you know i've been driving this jalopy
for six years
i gotta get a new car bro i'm dying
inside yeah right or you know what
i've been working hard i started making
30 grand a year then 50 grand now i'm
making a hundred grand a year i've
always wanted a new watch i always
wanted a rolex yeah all right cool
that's your one thing you know what i
got the most busted wardrobe like our
friend paul out there oh got the most
busted one so ugly time for me to ball
out in the mall time for me to get some
fresh gear and look good i want to i
want to hit the club i want to feel good
all right i get it
but pick one you ever heard the thing
you're doing too much bro
you're doing too much carrying the hose
bro yeah you got a new car now you got a
new watch now you can fly in private or
you're flying first class or you're
going to starbucks every single day
you're doing too much that's that
deserved mentality that's that treat you
treat yourself getting choked up over
here i'm sad for these people so
there's something that has been known in
the financial world that people probably
hear about all the time you're trying to
keep up with the joneses you're trying
to keep up with the joneses they say
that all the time now i don't know who
they're talking about i don't know if
they're talking about tommy lee jones or
james earl jones or freaking indiana
jones the jones is irrelevant you're
trying to keep
up with the joneses all right so
understand here's my advice here's like
all right great we're making fun of
these people but this isn't funny
in terms of like the reality of it
because you spend you spend you spend
next thing you know something happens
that oh [ __ ] now you're broke now your
net worth is nothing so here's my advice
here's my advice
if you get a raise
act
like you didn't get a raise for at least
six months
so they say that's fair they say
um when you win the lottery right and
i'm not comparing a you know uh going
from making 60 to making 100 or making
you know 80 to 100 or 80 to 120 as
winning the lottery but it is a windfall
right so there's advice of when you
you know have a windfall they say if you
win the lottery and also and you went
from just being like living in a trailer
house trailer trailer park
and now you've got 100 million dollars
what's the first thing you should do you
know what they say the first thing you
should do what's that do nothing
do
nothing they basically say let it simmer
let it marinate like a good pasta sauce
right
yeah it's burning a hole in my mouth i
gotta spend it
but basically they say do
nothing give it six months and just let
it just just just give it a second so
before you do anything major with this
windfall with this newfound 20 50 100
000 whatever additional income you have
just give it a minute bro let it
marinate
just take a second right take a chill
pill yeah take i mean obviously there's
a minor explaining i want to get 150
watch cool but i'm talking about going
and buying a 40 000 car
right or dropping 10 grand on a rolex or
going on a vacation where you're
dropping 10 grand fight you're going to
europe you're going to the philippines
you're going to thailand whatever so
here's what i did this is my advice
you know there was a time in my life
where like literally the most i ever
made up until i was 26 years old i was
doing stand-up comedy i was a club
promoter i was getting paid in drink
tickets i was getting paid in laughs i
was a substitute teacher i was getting
paid with boogers and snot from the kids
it wasn't a good look
but
then all of a sudden i made a hundred
grand i was 27 years old right
my my first year that i'm doing
financial sales i i literally made five
thousand dollars straight up like i went
from making 20 to five you're thinking
all right but it was an investment in
myself building a book of business boom
second year 2007 2008 right before the
crisis i made a hundred grand that was
[ __ ] ridiculous to me when you go
from 20 to 100 yeah you know what i did
what do you do i didn't do anything
i i still i lived on my with my
roommates
right i had some friends maybe i went
and got a little nice dinner to
celebrate yeah but i just save
that
money thank you for our spanish speakers
out there so here's my advice to you if
you make 50 grand you go to 100. if you
make 80 and you go to 100 you go 80 you
go to 120.
give it six months and literally do
nothing
don't run out the door to find your new
apartment don't you know run out the
door to find a new car don't go ball out
and get a new watch just let it marinate
and let cooler heads prevail
and you'll figure out long term what you
want to do with the money it's so easy
like you said it's burning a hole in my
pocket yeah can't get over this
just give it well a second i got a
question go ahead oh sorry but i heard a
feeling
i thought i
um all right so what would you suggest
to that person saying listen i i went to
that i have this debt and this credit
card debt or this car that i want to pay
off with this money okay what do you do
marinate and think or okay so that
that's that's smart so they say that
that only 20
of
financial
financial wellness
is
um
mental yeah 80
is behavioral meaning
i know
that i should pay off debt
i know that i should you know stack cash
i'm trying to ball out trying to ball
out trying to ball out right so what
you're bringing up is a very good point
you're right right if you got this if
you got 40 000 in loans and you just
made an extra 40 000
i'm not saying to pay it all off at once
but some of it most of it
whatever
like get you get out of that head get
out of that uh that hole that you're in
get out of that debt so
like i said so i'm at the point right
now i'm very open with my finances i'm
very i'll tell anybody what i'm worth
what i got whatever going on so ever
since basically 2008 with the exception
of one you know one year i've made over
one hundred thousand dollars okay yeah
so there's been years where i made two
hundred thousand there's made i made 300
the most i've ever made in a year is 500
000
pretty [ __ ] dope right but here's
what i've done
every single year of my life
i live like i still make a hundred
thousand dollars yeah you do okay
yeah you do a way to pick up a tab buddy
pick up a tapper
no i'll definitely uh no no
for his birthday yeah yeah yeah uh but
the point is this it's not like i'm
living you know i won't spend any money
i'm living like my my floor you know
there's a floor in the ceiling my floor
is 100 g's yeah i'm willing to like ball
out with that everything above that i'm
just saving and investing yeah okay so
let me wrap this up because i know we
got a lot of stories we want to cover
today there's a lot of things going on
out there david if you see anything in
the comments that stands out a question
you let me know because it's hard to
talk and look and think at the same time
you know how they say it's dave i'm also
reading just in case okay thank you
vanessa someone asked how tall i was i'm
about uh six four six four but minus a
foot um
so here's the deal
here's my advice to our friends out
there let me wrap let me put a bow on
this beautiful little segment we got
going on so we can move right
along in sports i'm a big sports guy you
got offense and you got defense the same
thing with money okay you got offense
and defense offense is how much money is
coming in defense is your expenses how
much money are you limiting going out
right you got offense and defense so
here's the analogy that i'll use and i'm
a huge basketball fan you know i used to
play i used the ball
back in the day there was a team in the
basically early 2000s called the phoenix
suns right they were just in the nba
finals this year devin booker chris paul
right we know what happened they lost in
the finals
um
but back in the 2000s they had a player
called steve nash everybody knows him as
one of the best point guards ever they
got amazing players amari stodomier sean
marion the matrix the andrew barbosa
they had a
sick squad they had the best offense in
the league they put up 125 points a game
sick
but you know how much they gave up a
game
126.
okay
so they're scoring buckets they had a
philosophy of like you gotta score in
the first five seconds they're running
down the court they're getting buckets
layups three-pointers they're killing it
but when push came to shove and they
actually had to d up
they would lose and the other team would
put up a little bit more points than
they did what's the analogy here
if you're making a hundred grand if
you're making 200 grand if you're making
more than that you got sick offense yeah
right you got sick offense
but you know what your problem is
probably got shitty ass defense yeah you
got you got leaks and holes all over
your squad and you got money
flying out the wazoo because why else
would you be living paycheck to paycheck
when you're making a hundred grand a
year okay even if you're in an expensive
city
so in my advice to you
offense defense understand what's coming
in
understand what's going out limit your
expenditures everybody's got the same
big three expenses your housing your
transportation and your food and
beverage and
you got to figure out which of those is
costing you way too much money right so
basically the bottom line is budget
understand what's coming in what's
coming out and that way you can start
building your net worth so all my
friends out there that make a hundred
grand a year keep it up but limit those
expenses
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauz cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken